van fleet's another
reason why this toronto team so good
defensively is brooker
raising up with a left man the
left-handed hammer over
by look he's measuring them
siakim your measurements are a little
off
i think it's where the the the number
one field goal percentage team
over 50 percent um number 13. get out of
here
field goal percentage team so um you
know they were looking to make strides
in that area
all right give me something watch some
shots get out of here
get that and field goal percentage team
over 50
um number 13. get out of here field goal
percentage team so
um you know they were looking to make
strides in that area
oh give me something let's give you
something right now give it to three of
the nuggets
have an early lead over the washington
wizards
alec burks worried number 20 ninth year
player from colorado
11 games so far as a sixer again they
got him
from the golden state warriors there
goes matisse thibault with a
major move and slam well done by the
rookie for his first hoop
wait to your second season the first
game that's when you're officially a
second year player
but he doesn't have time to waste and
tyler hero
so far doing everything well for miami
through these
first couple of scrimmages another
turnover the anthony milton
sends it ahead john moran sends it
through
well you don't normally see that kind of
creativity with that type of athleticism
well grizzlies able to play at pace
forcing turnovers and finishing
with a flourish sweeps it out robinson
quickly too
good hustle broken up the carl anderson
steal
the left for moran big time finish
for the rookie at a murray state rookie
point guard has hops
he runs the wings so hard
his second the rockets 17th and carson
edwards drives the lane
and the smallest celtic on the floor
slams it home
rudely with the left hand with the left
hand
where will he be where will he be used
post up on anderson early that's the
beauty of ben simmons the ability to
place him just about anywhere on the
floor
for a second there al had jabba rant no
one saw him unable to get it
uh take that let me interrupt you
because ben
simmons in rhythm hit him look at it
again here it is tobias
finds him like it's nothing
fans liking it is